MALIA DELL: Thank you very much.
Hello, thank you all
for coming today.
I am so excited to
be here speaking
at the Cambridge office
for Google for two reasons.
Firstly, Cambridge is
my old stomping ground,
and this is kind of where
I originally got the idea
to write "Food That Works."
And secondly, because without
an amazing tool like Google--
it took me four years
to write this book--
it would have taken
me over a decade
to amass amount of research
that this book required,
so thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you.
So today I wanted to
share my process of what
I did to write this book, the
research, writing the recipes,
illustrating the
book, food styling,
taking the photographs,
self-publishing, and now
I'm on a book tour
marketing my book.
So as Jonathan mentioned, "Food
That Works" is a food system.
It's not just, hey,
here's a bunch of recipes.
Good luck.
It gives you a
plan for the week,
so we don't have
to think about ugh,
what do I buy at the store?
What do I have at home?
What are we going
to eat this week?
None of us want to
think about that.
We're all busy, and this offers
you a guide, a strategic plan,
to survive the 9 to 5.
It offers five weeks
to choose from,
and it gives you shopping lists.
So you take the book right
to the store with you,
or on my website,
I have a shopping
lists that you can print out
that are printer friendly.
And you buy everything
on the list,
you get home from the store,
and there's prep work.
You bust it out real quick
kind of like a restaurant does
to prep all your
ingredients, so they
are readily available
to you during the week.
And then it gives
you recipes that
utilize all those ingredients,
so there's no waste,
so you don't think about
connecting those dots.
I kind of did all that
sweet math for you.
So ultimately, by prepping
your food in this way,
you will be able to have
access to more homemade meals
and have to settle
for less meals out.
Your fridge will kind
of be prepared is
this quick grab-and-go.
You can just slam together
food and out the door you go.
So that will save you
time during the week,
it'll save you money,
and ultimately, you'll
probably feel better
eating these homemade meals
instead of eating out.
I'll talk a bit more
about "Food That Works"
and how it's set
up, but first, I
want to give you a little
bit about my background
and the journey
creating this book.
I grew up all over the place,
but I'll give you the "Cliff
Notes" version here today.
I grew up in Honolulu, we lived
in Chicago, rural Vermont,
all over Massachusetts.
I studied abroad in
Florence, Italy in college.
Then I lived in southern
Spain, Turkey, and now
Mid-coast Maine.
I know, it's kind of
a wide stretch there.
But Massachusetts is where I
spent the majority of my time.
It's where I went to
high school and college.
And right out of college, I
got a really great job working
for Gap, Inc. Doing
corporate real estate,
and the office is
actually in Waltham.
And settling into this
new job and my commute,
I realized how difficult
it was to feed myself well
during the week.
I didn't know how to cook.
I wasn't really interested
in learning how to cook,
and I didn't really
eat all that well.
But I kind of just assumed
that since I was busy,
this was the way
that it had to be.
So on the way to work,
I would stop and pick up
something for breakfast.
For lunch, I would go
down to the office park
and grab something in
the limited cafeteria.
Then for dinner, I'd get
home, swing open the fridge.
Eh, no food, and I
would order takeout.
So I'm sure a lot of us
can relate to this routine,
and it's easy to do
when you live in a city.
But I was feeding myself
terribly three times a week,
and I didn't even know it.
My energy was zapped.
Getting myself to go to the
gym was a daily struggle.
And why was my energy
drained at 22 years old
is really my question.
But I just continued this cycle
for several years actually.
And today one of the
most common questions
that people ask me is what
motivated you to write a book?
And it's a really good question.
And my most common
response is I wanted
to capture a weekly
plan for people,
so they didn't have to
recreate the wheel that
offered shopping lists, prep
work, and recipes in one spot.
And I couldn't find a
cookbook that did this easily,
so I wrote one
myself, which is true.
But when I really think back
to what my motivation was
to start cooking for
myself 26 years old,
it was because I wanted
to live in Spain,
I wanted to go back to Europe.
And I started cooking for myself
and prepping my meals for work
not because I wanted
to lose weight
or because I wanted
to eat better.
It was because I
wanted to save money.
I wanted to take a year
off, go back to Europe,
and move to Spain,
and learn Spanish,
and that was a
huge goal of mine.
So how was I going
to make this happen?
I decided that I need to
save X amount of dollars
so I could take a
year off from work.
Then I was going to
buy a plane ticket.
So prepping my food
became something
that I wanted to get into.
The first thing that I decided I
had to do to start saving money
was-- I was making really great
money at my corporate job,
but I was spending a
ridiculous amount of money
out each week on
food and beverage.
So I realized that I
was spending $7 a day
on a venti triple
pump Chai latte.
That's $140 a month.
So I made a rule for
myself I was no longer
allowed to get Chai lattes out.
If I wanted one so bad, then
I could make it for myself,
which I just didn't.
And to my surprise, I got
over my heavy Chai addiction.
I just started realizing
that these foods that I
was putting into
my body every day
were actually slowing me down.
And whenever I had the
urge to get a Chai,
I would think Spain,
Chai, Spain-- OK, easy.
So I decided that I want
to start cooking for myself
and prepping meals, and
I wasn't very good at it.
I wasn't really succeeding.
I had a loose plan when I'd
go to the grocery store,
and I didn't have
recipes in mind.
I would kind of just
throw things in my cart.
And then I would get
home, put it all away,
and realize that
during the week,
it was a lot harder
to assemble meals
from all these random
things than to actually have
a plan going into it, right?
So I figured that I need to
have some sort of strategy
to be better at this.
Because it's a lot more
difficult to--poof!--
just come up with a random meal
from all these ingredients.
And I was wasting a lot of food,
which made me feel terrible.
I'm crazy about
food waste, and I
think that we all can do a lot
better on the household level
reducing our food waste.
So that was kind of a mission
that motivated me as well.
And it actually is
really satisfying
when you get to the point where
you're really good at your food
shop, and you get home, and
utilize all your ingredients,
and everything gets
used up beautifully.
And it really deepens
your respect with food
and helps you
connect to your food.
Does anyone here have those
really successful food shops
every week where you use every
single ingredient and nothing
goes bad in your fridge?
Anybody?
No, no, no.
Yeah, see, because it's
difficult. It's not easy,
and that takes planning.
And luckily, I'm pretty
good at this game.
My friends call me
the Cupboard Queen
because I love showing up
to a friend's house who's
like, I have no food.
And I rustle around in their
cabinets and in their fridge,
and am like, OK, if
we chop some of this,
add a little bit of that,
and add a can of beans,
then we can make tacos.
And I do, I love that
challenge, but I don't love it
on a Tuesday night when I get
home from work, and I'm tired
and I'm hungry.
Who would do that to themselves?
So I realized that I have
this 1o-minute window
when I get in the
door and I'm hungry,
if there aren't healthful
options nearby quick for me
to grab, I will tear into
a bag of anything that
is closest, right?
So I've destroyed an
entire box of Triscuits
just waiting for my
dinner to heat up.
Oh, you've done it.
Come on.
So sometimes when I
get home from work,
I feel like Chris Farley.
You know in that SNL skit with
David Spade and Adam Sandler?
"Lay off me.
I'm starving!"
That's how I get it, and I'm
sure you can relate to that.
I know this about
myself, and I realized
that in order to feed myself
the way that I want to eat,
I need to have prepared
whole foods in my fridge
ready to grab on the fly.
And whole foods do take
a little love and prep.
You can't just
bite into a potato.
You do have to cook it.
But that's what this
book aims to help you do.
And I learned that the only way
to succeed at feeding myself
homemade meals three times a
day, Monday through Friday,
was to have a plan when
I went to the store,
to prep those ingredients
so that they were
quick and easy to grab, and
throw into meals, and assemble,
and lastly, minimal
cleanup because-- I'm
sure you can all
agree with me-- I
don't want to do
dishes during the week.
And this book helps
you so you don't
have to get the cutting board
out twice and make a mess.
And it's all kind of
planned out for you,
so the recipes are
really minimal,
minimal cleanup, minimal tools.
So my homemade food
began becoming so good
that I was no longer eating
out, and I didn't really
miss it to be honest.
My confidence in
the kitchen grew.
I started teaching myself how
to prepare the meals that I
was normally ordering out.
And that way, I could cook
them however I liked them.
So, say, in my chili,
if I love extra beans,
I could add extra beans.
So that was really a neat
learning moment for me,
was understanding that by
cooking, I have more power
to create the meals the
way that I love them,
and I don't need to settle
for the alternate out.
And my confidence
grew, and I started
modifying these recipes
to have more healthful
ingredients and little
ingredient substitutions.
So that's also what's great
about "Food That Works."
It's really flexible.
If you're a vegetarian, you
can substitute out things,
and I really recommend
people doing that.
These recipes are
just guidelines.
There's really not many rules.
They're there for you to change
and fix however you like them.
And don't get me wrong.
I love my fine
dining experience.
I love eating out.
Sometimes there's nothing that
I appreciate more than going
to a restaurant and being
served beautiful food
that a ton of love and thought
went into by a team of chefs,
and to share that food
across the table from someone
special in some sexy ambiance.
But those are special occasions,
and they have their place
in life.
And they're very
different from stopping
for a bagel, or a sub, a
gas station slice of pizza.
What I'm interested
in is our daily meals,
and the ways in which we choose
to feed ourselves three times
a day.
And I learned quickly
from my experience that
not being prepared, I was forced
to settle for all these meals
out and sign up for these
sub-par ingredients,
and foods that were
full of extra added fat,
and preservatives, and
things that I really didn't
want to be putting in my body.
But since I wasn't
prepared, I had to do it,
and it would always
be disappointed.
When you spend top dollar for
a meal for the cheapest quality
ingredients-- for example, when
you buy a $15 salad, and you
look down at it.
It's a tub of iceberg lettuce
with a portion of chicken
that's this big,
and three olives,
and a little ring of red onion.
You're like, man, I could
have made this so much better
had I just been prepared.
So I decided that I wasn't going
to settle for my meals anymore,
and that I could do
better, and that I needed
to make my meals a priority.
So thank goodness
that I had connected
with my motivator, this
bigger goal of going to Spain.
Because had I not, I wouldn't be
where I am today in my career,
and to be here speaking
with you today.
So initially, my motivator
was to save money,
but then I felt a
shift in my health.
I felt I had more energy, my
skin cleared up, I was happier,
I slept better,
and hey, my clothes
fit a little bit better.
And there's so many perks when
you start cooking for yourself,
and it's endless.
Just the joy of finding
this hobby that you love,
and then also all of
the physical perks,
and just improving your
memory, and your health.
And it just really,
really impacted my life,
and that's why I decided to
kind of try and capture it
in this book for other people.
So I encourage you to
find your motivators.
You work hard, and you deserve
quality food three times a day.
So whether your motivation is
to alleviate a health issue,
to fit into those skinny
jeans in your closet,
to increase your
stamina for life,
to be more
self-sufficient, maybe it's
to set an example
for your children,
or maybe it's just
so that you can
be a more useful
human in the event
that we have a zombie apocalypse
or something like that.
I started bringing
my leftovers to work,
and the smell started
wafting through the office.
And my curious coworkers
would come over and be like,
what is that?
You made that?
How do you time to
cook all this food?
And it really wasn't until my
coworkers started asking me
for my recipes that I thought I
might be on to something here.
This is a tool that a
lot of us could use.
And so I thought,
well, maybe I'll
just bind this little
pamphlet for my coworkers
and give it to
them and as a gift.
And that is truly how the idea
to write "Food That Works"
began.
I never set out to write
a 166-page cookbook.
It was more these serendipitous
little events that
triggered this path for me.
So shortly after
that, I started kind
of keeping my successful
shopping lists,
and my little
scribbled down recipes
that were on
napkins and whatnot,
tucking them into a folder
just for future reference
in case I'm going to put
this package together
for my coworkers who kept
asking me to email them recipes.
And only a couple
months later, I
ended up reaching
my savings goal.
I knew if I didn't go to
Spain, that I would regret it
for the rest of my life.
I had to do it.
So in 2011, I gave
notice at work,
I packed up my life
here in Boston,
I bought a backpack and a
one-way ticket to Spain.
And I had no idea how
this trip living abroad
was going to impact
the rest of my life,
but the unknown
was a place that I
felt like I needed to hang
out in for a little while.
So I trusted, I took a leap of
faith, and I got on the plane.
And just a side note
here, I use this website
called Workaway, which you
might want to write down.
It's amazing, this website.
Workaway.info, and it's
volunteer opportunities
all over the world.
So host families will
welcome you into their home,
and they offer you your
room and all of your meals,
and in exchange, all you do
is volunteer for them 25 hours
a week.
So this is how I was able
to afford to stay over there
for a year on my minimalist
little gypsy budget.
And the projects are amazing.
Anything that you're good at,
someone needs help with that.
So the projects range from
help us release turtles
into the wild in
Costa Rica, or help
us harvest lavender
in southern France,
or help us paint a mural in
our home in southern Spain.
So I encourage you to
check out this website.
It's so amazing,
and maybe it'll just
help you plan your next trip.
I ended up living with
these beautiful host
families for nine months
in Spain and Turkey.
And I kind of had the idea
that I wanted to do this book.
So any chance that I had, I
was in the kitchen observing,
asking them what they're doing,
taking notes in my journal.
I was the first to volunteer
to go to the grocery store,
so I was kind of picking
up all these little tips
that I was learning in
the Mediterranean while
living over there.
After nine months,
I ran out of money.
And, again, I knew I
wanted to start this book,
and I needed to be near American
grocery stores to do so.
So I was ready to come home.
But at that moment, I realized
just how gypsy I really am,
and I realized I don't actually
have a home to return to.
And this would freak
a lot of people out,
but considering my life has been
a series of moving and planting
new roots, it was something
that I was accustomed to,
and it didn't really faze me.
My parents happen
to have been living
in Mid-coast Maine at the
time, so I thought, oh, I'll
put my backpack down there,
say hi to my parents,
give them a kiss
because I miss them,
and then figure out what
my next step would be.
It didn't take long for me to
realize that Maine is magical,
and I thought that it would
be the best place for me
to give birth to this book.
Good place to focus, hibernate.
So not long after I landed
on the shores of Maine,
I met a man who asked
me to house-sit for him
and take care of his cats.
And he had this funky
studio artist loft
space that used be
a church that he
converted into
this awesome space,
and he asked me to house-sit.
So what started off
as will you house it
for me for three weeks turned
into six weeks, turned into six
months, turned into I've
been living in that space,
working on this book full-time
for the past three years.
So it's been pretty
amazing, and like I said,
all the things kind of pushed
me towards finishing this book.
And it's been such an
amazing journey so far.
So I immediately
started doing research.
I spent a lot of
time at the library
and at the good old
American grocery store,
researching ingredients, doing
calculations, figuring out
all the quantities that
you see in the shopping
list on the book,
and making sure
that the ingredients get
utilized and nothing goes
to waste.
And to support myself while
I was writing the manuscript,
I began working at this
restaurant called Primo.
It's a very special
restaurant in Maine.
And the chef who
owns it, her name
is Melissa Kelly, the two-times
James Beard Award-winning chef.
She is such a force.
She is so amazing.
And I really, truly
learned what hard work
was from watching her.
But Primo is a farm-to-table
restaurant in the true sense.
They have their
animals in the back.
They raise pigs and
chickens every year.
They grow all of
their vegetables
and harvest them fresh, and
it's what you see on your plate.
So the synergy of that
place is just so amazing,
and it really taught me
to connect with my food,
and understand
where it came from,
and the cycle of life
of plants and animals.
So learning from
her in her kitchen
and just watching this
amazing restaurant that
functioned as this machine, I
learned the pace of a kitchen,
and how important it is to
bust out one task, clean up,
move onto the next thing.
I learned the importance of
prepping your ingredients, so
your mise en place, right?
So before every shift,
I would watch the chefs.
They would chop all of
their ingredients, all
of their garnish,
everything would be
perfectly ready and organized.
So when an order came
in, they were just like,
handful of this, handful
of this, plate, next.
Handful of this, handful
And that's what I wanted to
capture in "Food That Works,"
is this is the most
efficient way to do it.
This is how they're
rocking it in this kitchen.
There has to be a way that
I can apply this for myself
in my home kitchen.
Also, like I mentioned,
I learned a great amount
of respect for food
working in a restaurant.
I don't know if any of you have
ever worked in a restaurant,
but it is hard work,
and just understanding
that all of these ingredients
took a lot of effort to create.
And just really if every
single thing in a kitchen
gets utilized, then it
can get utilized again.
And then even after
that, it goes to compost
or it goes to feed the animals.
So I really wanted
to incorporate
that in my book and
kind of ease people
into really respecting
their ingredients.
If you buy it at
the store, having
a duty to use up
the chicken breast
that you bought because that
once was an animal's life.
I also learned the importance
of keeping an organized fridge,
labeling things, keeping
food in rotation,
knowing what needs to
get used up first--
that was a great lesson
for me-- and just how
to run an efficient kitchen.
And this experience of working
at Primo that kind of landed
in my lap, it really
influenced the organization
that you see in
"Food That Works."
So it basically teaches you
how to be your own sous chef.
And whenever you order a
salad out or a sandwich out,
someone came into work
that day and chopped up
all those ingredients,
and I'm teaching you
that you can do that type
of prep work for yourself,
and I walk you through it.
So at this point, I
had the manuscript,
and I realized it
was really rough,
and I realized that I needed
people to test my recipes.
I had tested them, but you
need other people to test them.
And most cookbook
authors will hire people
and pay them to test
each recipe, sometimes
multiple times.
But I didn't have that luxury.
So I finished the five
weeks, and then I decided,
how can I figure out a way
to have people test this?
And there was this class in
college called Research Methods
that was required of
all sociology majors
to take in their senior year.
And I dreaded this
class at the time,
and I thought ugh-- just
going to through motions-- how
is this ever going
to apply to my life?
Well, it was the
very skills that I
learned in that class
that enabled me to come up
with a plan to have
my book and my recipes
tested nationwide for free.
I targeted a sample
population of people.
I requested their participation.
I sent out surveys and
recipes for them to test,
and I solicited
the feedback that I
needed in order to improve
my recipes in my book.
I collected all the
data, analyzed it,
and incorporated the changes.
And ultimately, it
improved my book,
so it's easier for
other people to follow.
So after I did all
of that, I ended up
writing a big thank you
letter to my Research Methods
professor, telling her how her
class that affected my life.
And she was elated because I
am sure that professors don't
always get to hear back
from their students years
later of how their
class impacted them,
but we stayed in touch,
and she's now the chair
of the sociology department.
And next week I've been invited
to return to my Alma Mater
and speak to those
very students who
are sitting in that
Research Methods class,
so it kind of comes full circle.
This book took me
four years to write.
And around year two, I had
some big decisions to make.
I thought, do I keep
going and investing
all of my time and money
in this massive project?
Do I actually reel
in professionals
and get editors and
designers involved?
Or do I just throw in the towel
and get a real job that pays?
After much reflection
and some tears,
I decided that I had to
finish, that I had a good idea,
and that this book could
help a lot of people.
And as Googlers, I
know you understand
the importance of a good idea.
And when we have them,
we have a moral duty
to bring them out
into the world.
So I decided to hire freelance
editors and cookbook designers
to complete this book.
And I had never hired a
freelance anything before,
so I Googled how to hire
a freelance editor, what
is the difference between a
copy editor and a proofreader,
how to negotiate a contract
with a freelance designer?
So I educated myself
on the process.
I ended up hiring an amazing
team of designers called
Camden Design and a
great team of editors
who are in Washington DC,
Cookbook Construction Crew.
And since I have a
captured audience here,
I'm just going to
throw this out there.
"Food That Works" has
been out for 90 days now,
and not one person has found
a typo in "Food That Works,"
and that's unheard of.
It's my first book, so either
no one's found a typo yet,
or that was some
damn thorough editing
that we did for 18 months.
So I'm just going
to throw it out
there to everyone who's here,
a little challenge, if you are
able to find a typo
in "Food That Works,"
and you let me know about it,
I will buy you a Chai latte.
So contact me.
Seriously, I would
love to hear from you.
So then it came to completing
the book, wrapping it up.
I taught myself to food style.
I food styled all the shots
that you see in the photographs.
I took most of the photographs
in "Food That Works,"
and hired photographers
to help me
with ones that I couldn't take.
And I illustrated the book.
All those little doodles you
see, that's me having fun.
And it was really
important for me
that it was a user
friendly guide.
How do I turn what I was
doing in my own kitchen
and how I was
rocking out, how do I
turn that into
something, a manual
that people could
actually follow?
So it was really
crucial that the design
was simple and basic.
I didn't want people have to
turn the book to figure out
what they were doing next.
It's supposed to save you
time, not be a daunting thing.
So the designers
really heard me,
and I love the way
the book came out.
It's exactly how I
envisioned, and I am
so proud of the final product.
It's receiving amazing
reviews online,
and it's doing far better than I
ever, ever could have imagined.
I would be lying if I stood
here and painted this project
as all peaches and prosecco.
There was a lot of
challenges, and it
was a huge undertaking for
someone in their 20s to commit
to, or anyone for that matter.
And there was a lot
of pressure because I
self-funded the production
of the entire book myself
and did so on a
very minimal budget.
But it was the very project that
had me jumping out of my bed
every single day before
my alarm went off.
I was so passionate
about working
on this, and every free minute
that I had, I was in love.
I was committed.
And I wanted to see this thing
through and get it out there
to the world.
So basically
working on this book
was like creating my own
graduate thesis project, right?
It took about the
same amount of time.
It cost the same.
And instead of having a piece of
paper to show you for my work,
I have this book that you
now hold in your hands.
So now I'll explain a little bit
of how "Food That Works" works.
Like I said, it's
more than a cookbook.
It's a food system.
It has five weeks.
If you look at the pages
on the side of the book,
there's all different
colored tabs.
And the five weeks in "Food
That Works" have themes.
So you pick a theme
that sounds good to you.
For example, red week is
Italian-American type dishes,
and blue week is
Mediterranean theme,
and orange week is
Mexican-Southwestern.
So you pick a menu that
sounds good to you.
You're like, yeah, I want to
eat turkey tacos, and burgers,
and meatballs this week.
And I actually tried
to pick recipes
that I feel like we
all know and love,
and things that we
typically order out.
And you bring that week
to the store with you.
So say you're like, yeah,
I want to do green week,
you shop from the green
week shopping list.
And like I said,
it's all figured out.
It's all whole foods.
This book is really trying
to help you move away
from purchasing processed and
packaged versions of the foods
that you love, and
instead, ease you
into cooking more for yourself.
And it's kind of a game for me
when I go to the grocery store.
I'm looking at
all the ingredient
labels on the back and kind
of like, what's in this now?
I'm not getting that.
And really trying to challenge
myself to find the best quality
and not settle for all
these extra additives,
and preservatives, and things.
So the book talks a lot
about quality of ingredients,
and there's a whole
section on how
to shop for them while
you're at the store.
Because as we all know,
once you get it home,
you're going to eat it, right?
So it's making the smart choices
while you're at the store
and really knowing what's in it.
And I really urge people to
read the ingredient label
and select the version
that has the least
amount of listed ingredients.
There's also an ingredient
guide in the back of the book.
There's 50-plus
entries in there,
I believe, that I wrote
that are all descriptions
about each ingredient
in "Food That Works."
So say you have a
question about something
when you're at the store.
You're like, what's Braggs?
I don't know what that
is, or where it's located.
You can flip to the
back of the book,
and it explains what
it is, how to store it,
the nutritional benefits.
So I definitely encourage
you to check that out
because I wrote all
of those for you.
And then when you go
home from the store,
this is the most crucial
part of "Food That Works,"
it's doing your prep.
So there's a little
prep list in there,
and it says, OK, here we go.
We're getting this in the
kitchen, turns some music on,
we're going to bang this out.
So you chop all of
your vegetables up,
you get the oven going, you bake
some chicken breast just plain,
you bake some
sweet potatoes, you
get some hard boiled eggs
going, and you're just
moving through it.
So during the week,
when you're hungry,
you can just grab a
plain chicken breast
and turn it into whatever meal
it is that you're in the mood
for.
It's more like a
blank canvas that's
sitting there for you to
make a creation with, right?
And same with all
the vegetables.
You can grab handful of
this, handful of this.
Boom, omelette.
Out the door.
You only have one
thing to clean,
which is the pan, and maybe the
fork if you eat with a fork.
And so it's the
same with dinner.
You get home.
You're starving.
You're just, handful of this,
handful of this, pasta dinner.
So it's really teaching you.
It's nothing glamorous or crazy.
This is cooking
Monday through Friday.
I didn't try to make this
whole elaborate thing.
I tried to keep it
very simple for you
because I'm sure I'm
in the same boat.
When I get home, I'm hungry, and
I don't want to think about it.
It just needs to happen
quickly so nobody gets hurt.
And like I said before, it's
all crossover ingredients.
So it teaches you the art of
OK, I bought these peppers.
They're all chopped, but I
don't just have one meal in mind
to use them for.
I know now that I can
put them in, and this,
and this, and this.
So it teaches you how to
use up those ingredients.
And I found that when I do
spend the time prepping my food,
I'm more likely to use
those ingredients, right?
Because now I've
invested time in it,
and I've spent time
chopping it or cooking it.
And so I when I peer
into my fridge, for me,
it's not usually a question
of what do I want to eat now?
What am I in the mood for?
It's more, OK, what do
I need to eat first?
What's going bad first, right?
So that's how you keep
that food in rotation
and use it up
before it goes bad.
And the best part
about "Food That Works"
is it turns your fridge into
the ultimate grab-and-go.
So, like I said, it's your
own salad bar basically.
You look in there.
It's a sexy fridge.
It's all organized.
You can see what's in there.
You know that everything
is fresh and new.
And you can grab handfuls,
and make creations, and boom,
you're out the door.
I really tried to make
these meals portable
because I, personally,
don't eat many of my meals
from home, at the
actual home anymore.
And I think with our
schedules today, many of us
don't, and that's
the reality of it.
With that being said, I like
to show people and emphasize
that even though we don't eat
many of our meals in the home,
it doesn't mean that we
can't have homemade meals.
Also, this book teaches
you to modify, like I said.
Anything that you like,
you can add extra of that,
and it will taste good to you.
There's not many rules
in "Food That Works."
And once you get
in the kitchen, you
feel liberated because
you start to learn like,
oh, if I just add extra
this, then yeah, it's great.
And so that's really
when it becomes fun.
And it's really supposed to be
a casual book and a refreshing
approach to getting
back in the kitchen
and shopping for ourselves.
And I'm going to read
a little page here
from "Food That Works" quickly.
These are just tips.
Again, there's not many
rules in "Food That Works"
because I don't like
rules, and I don't
subscribe to many of them.
But some tips in "Food
That Works"-- first, I
mention read ingredient labels.
Brand, package, color--
none of that matters.
All you care about is
the ingredients label.
A long list indicates that
it's highly processed.
Your body doesn't want all that.
Just put it back.
Shoot for 10
ingredients or fewer.
Compare different brands
and select the one
with the fewest
listed ingredients.
So that's that
challenge I was talking
about when you're in the store.
For example, a can of beans
should read beans, water, salt.
Clean and simple.
Second, by single
ingredient foods.
Potatoes, peppers,
apples, tomatoes--
these are whole foods.
Picture things that you can
see growing out in nature.
Single ingredients.
And when you look down at your
cart after shopping this way,
you'll be surprised when you
see more recognizable foods
and less packaging, and
ink, and advertising.
Third, refuse to buy anything
that lists high fructose
or hydrogenated in
the ingredients list.
Like I said, I don't subscribe
to many rules in life,
but this is one
that I do not break.
Simply decided to eliminate
these from your diet,
and you are already winning.
It doesn't have to be a
huge complicated thing.
But if you decide not to
eat these two ingredients
and you're reading
labels, it really
weeds out the amount of
things that you can buy,
and that you'll sign up to eat.
Fourth, stick to the list.
These lists will prevent
impulse purchases
and allow for quick
navigation through the store.
So stick to your
mission, in and out.
And this book will help
you save time there
so you have time to pursue
the other things in life
that you're passionate about.
I know we don't all want to
spend tons of time shopping
and prepping our food, so
this is supposed to help you.
And lastly, buy organic.
I have a whole section
in the book that
talks about organic, what
it is, why it's important,
especially for certain
foods in particular.
But eating organic foods
reduces our pesticide intake.
Especially with produce,
make the splurge for organic.
You're worth it.
So as you can tell, cooking
has profoundly changed my life.
And what next?
Well, now I speak.
I speak at companies
and universities
all over the country about this
habit of cooking for ourselves.
And lots of people will
say cooking is addictive,
and I see all the
non-cooks in the room
always roll their eyes.
And it's not that
cooking is addictive.
It's that learning is addictive.
And that's what my
book aims to do,
is to get you addicted
to learning about what's
in your food, and how it was
grown, and where the heck
it came from.
And from there, there
are so many things
that this brings to our lives.
Our brains seek novel
experiences and innovation,
and cooking utilizes all
five of our senses, right?
From selecting it, to
smelling it, to prepping it,
to cooking it, to then
sitting down and eating it.
And I know that cooking may
not be the desire for everybody
in the room, but
considering it's something
we have to do three times
a day, is feed ourselves,
it's not exactly a bad
hobby to entertain.
And I want to show people
that changing your diet
doesn't have to be this
huge, extreme overhaul.
It starts with small changes
and the decision to start.
And I've seen lovely
reviews that people
have left online after
cooking through this book.
And some of them say, yeah,
I don't cook every week
from "Food That Works."
I don't use it religiously.
But now I keep a thing of
hard boiled eggs in my fridge
at all times.
So that when I'm hungry and I'm
on the go, I can just grab one,
throw it in my bag,
and I'm out the door.
It's a great protein
snack, and I love it.
So it's these small
things that you pick up
that you incorporate into
your world that work for you.
And the glory, like I said,
of cooking for yourself
is that you can modify.
I can't say that whenever I
cook any of my own recipes,
they ever come out the same.
They're always different.
And I encourage you to
sneak in new ingredients,
and drop things
that you don't like.
I hope that this
book really helps
people think about cooking
differently and not that it
needs to be this daunting chore
that we have to get through,
but instead, a
creative, fun challenge.
So now that I've been
talking for a while,
I want to talk a little
bit about wellness,
and I'm really
encouraged to know
that Google fosters a
culture here that really
breeds creativity and wellness.
And in a small way, that's
what my book aims to do,
to help people achieve a
healthy lifestyle, both at home
and at work.
Considering we spend so much
time at our jobs these days,
it's important to focus
on that part of it.
And I recently heard
this adage that I really
liked, which is you spend
one hour at the gym,
but it's what you do in the
other 23 hours of the day that
really matters.
And I really liked
thinking about that
because how can we
take care of ourselves
better in the other 23 hours?
And there's many things that
contribute to our wellness.
It's not just diet and gym.
And in wellness
coaching, we go at it
with a more holistic
approach of all
of the aspects of our wellness.
So there was actually a really
great talk at Google in 2012
by Kelly McGonigal.
She's an author and
health psychologist
at Stanford University.
And in her talk, she
talks about the brain,
and how it functions,
and the four facets
that really affect our brain
function and our productivity,
therefore, affecting our
decision-making and will power.
And the four things
that she talked about
were exercise, meditation,
sleep, and diet.
So let's start with exercise.
I'm going to ask you if you'd
please stand, and join me,
and we're going to do
a couple exercises just
to get moving around
a little bit, just
to wake us up before we
all head back to our desks.
So first, if you can start with
your feet hips width apart.
And you're just going to gently
twist, swinging your arms,
nothing crazy.
Don't hurt yourself.
We're not going to
break a sweat here.
Just letting your hands bang
against your lower back.
This is good for the lower back
if you've been sitting a lot.
It's a good massage
for the kidneys,
stimulates the kidneys.
And breathe.
And smile.
It helps to smile while
you're doing this.
No one's looking at you.
Don't worry.
It feels good.
And you can do this
any time your desk
if you feeling that 3:00
PM slump hitting you
in the face like
a ton of bricks.
So the next one, I
like to call it you
pull down with your arms, and
you're bringing your knee up.
So it's not about speed.
It's about control.
So really crunching your
abs when you come down.
This is good for the hips.
Loosen up the hip joints.
You've been sitting
your car, long commute.
Just pulling down, pulling down.
And breathe and smile.
And then the next move is
a similar move to that.
I'm going to turn
this way for you.
You're pulling with your
arms, and basically you
want to keep them at
90 degrees and almost
make your two shoulder blades
kiss in the back, right?
So it's a pull and a butt
kick, kicking behind you.
This is good for your quads.
It's good for your
shoulders if you've
been typing at your computer.
Ah, feels so good.
And these are things you can do.
These are available
to you any time.
I know your co-workers might
think you're a little weird,
but this will wake you up.
I swear, it's like
a cup of coffee.
And you're already here.
You can go right
into the running man
if you're feeling that.
Preps you right for it
if you're feeling funky.
There's actually one more
that I want to show you.
This is my favorite one.
It's a shoulder stretch.
It's actually for your neck.
We hold a lot of tension
and stress in our necks.
So you're going to
take your left hand,
bring it behind your body.
Grab it with your right hand.
And then you're going to
tilt to your right ear
to your right shoulder.
And it's elongating these
muscles in your neck.
So wherever you feel the
tension in your neck,
you just want to breathe into
it and visualize the muscle.
Take a deep breath.
Letting go of any of that
tension that we hold there.
Bring it over to the other side.
Whenever I'm doing
stretches, I don't like
to just go through the motions.
It's really about putting
your mind in that muscle,
and thinking about it loosening.
All right, bring it back.
Take a seat.
Thank you very much.
So the next one that she
talks about was meditation.
Silencing our minds for
just a few moments a day
has amazing effects on
our responses physically
and emotionally to stress.
So don't worry.
I'm not going to make
you meditate right now,
but I would like to ask you
to please close your eyes.
Try to clear your
mind for a moment.
Take a big inhale.
And exhale through your mouth.
Relax the muscles in your face.
Now I'd like you to
visualize someone who
brings great joy to your life.
And smile.
If you were able to
thank them right now,
what would you say the them?
In your head, say
their name and smile.
Now open your eyes.
Feels good, doesn't it?
Just a few moments in
gratitude and making
the decision to smile can really
relax you throughout the day.
Smiling releases
endorphins, and who
can't use a good dose of
endorphins at 3 o'clock
on a Thursday, right?
So that is available
to you at any time.
If you're feeling stressed,
you can close your eyes
and visualize someone that
you really care about.
It helps.
The next one was sleep.
Sleep is so important for us.
It affects every part of our
lives, and our decision-making,
and our productivity,
our personal lives,
and our work lives.
And I'll be honest with you.
Over the course of writing
this book for four years,
I suffered from a
serious bout of insomnia.
It was terrible.
I tell you, I would not
wish that on anyone.
It's a curse.
And so now I really, really
take my sleep seriously.
It affected everything.
It affected my food choices.
I was more prone to
grab sugary things
and junk to artificially power
me through my exhaustion.
I was short with my
friends and my family,
and it was miserable.
I was miserable to be around.
I didn't even want
to be around me.
So I encourage you.
If your sleep is an
area of your wellness
that you would like
to improve upon,
only you can make
that a priority,
and change your habits
around nighttime
when you're ready to go to bed.
And really consider it
as an important thing
that you deserve to
get a good eight hours,
and work on that if
it's a goal for you.
I tried to work five minutes of
sleep into this talk right now,
but I couldn't really swing it.
And lastly, our diets.
So coming full circle,
back to what we eat.
There's so many fads, and
cleanses, and detoxes,
and all these things today,
and it seems so complicated.
And my approach is far more
simple and maintainable.
It's cook your own damn food.
When you cook for
yourself at home,
you're not signing up for all
these extra additives, right?
So when you make a
homemade lasagna,
you don't sprinkle
monosodium glutamate
on it or preservatives.
And when you make
homemade granola,
you're not drizzling
high fructose corn syrup
all over it.
Cooking for yourself
and cooking at home
is clean and simple by nature.
So that is all we're
trying to get back to here.
It's not rocket science.
It's putting foods that
we like on a plate.
The hard part is doing
it within our schedules,
but you have to make
yourself a priority.
And I'm here today to tell
you that it is possible to do,
and I wrote "Food That Works"
in order to help you get there.
So let's spare ourselves the
obesity, the health issues,
the insecurities about food, and
instead, know our ingredients
and how to cook them.
You can start tonight.
It's not far from your reach.
It's about the distance
from your grocery store
to your kitchen.
It's you, the tenacious,
hard working Americans,
that inspired me to
write "Food That Works."
Fuel your body with the
best ingredients possible,
and you are creating a
platform from which to launch
your talents into the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think we're doing
a little Q&A now.
If anyone has any questions,
food-related questions,
shopping questions, you
can just come up to the mic
and ask your questions
so everyone can hear you.
AUDIENCE: So I had gotten the
book at the beginning of this.
And I when I was
scanning through,
you had some little
tips in here.
And there was a
section about PLUs,
and I thought that
was fascinating.
If you could just say that
to everybody in case somebody
is not getting the book,
that would be appreciated.
MALIA DELL: Yes, thank you.
Yeah, there's a great
section in there
that talks about
organic, why it's
important to select organics,
certain foods that you should
look for, and words
that you should
look for on the packaging.
And one thing that I
learned during the research
for this book is, you
know the little stickers
that you see on the produce
at the grocery store?
It's called a PLU sticker,
which is a price look up code.
And basically any sticker that
you see that starts with a 4--
so it'll be like,
4695-- anything
that starts with a number
4 is commercially grown.
So that means that
they do use pesticides,
and you don't exactly
know what's on it.
And so in order to reduce
your pesticide intake when
you buy commercially
grown produce--
because I can't always afford
to buy everything organic--
but the things that I
buy commercially grown,
I'm sure to peel or scrub
really well, wash really well.
So that's how you know if
it's commercially grown.
And if you see a number
9 starting the number,
that means that it's organic.
So that's a fun,
little tip for you when
you're at the grocery store.
You can check it
out and make sure
that things are
in the right bins.
Because sometimes like,
what kind of apple is this?
It's a little confusing.
So thanks, that's a good point.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if we wanted
to create our own
weekly plan, do
you have a suggestion for
a strategy for planning
those such that you use
up all the ingredients?
Because I do plan my
meals, but I'm really
terrible at using everything.
So I was just
wondering if you had
a general strategy when you'
were putting those together.
MALIA DELL: I love to hear that
you're making your own weeks
because that's awesome.
I guess I would say
you can do it two ways.
You could probably
start from whatever
your favorite ingredients are
that you use across the board.
So say, for example,
you love potatoes.
And then I would find a bunch
of recipes that use potatoes,
and kind of build
out from that so
that I knew that I could use
it up in multiple things.
So you could start
with the ingredient
and build out a
shopping list from that.
Or you could start off
with recipes that you like.
And then read the lists on the
recipes, and say, OK, well,
it says that I need this
many peppers for this,
I need this many
peppers for this one.
OK, so I need to buy four
peppers for this whole week.
But my biggest recommendation is
prepping that food in advance.
That's going to save you so
much time during the week.
You're not going to want
to do it during the week,
and that's the sad part.
It's like, we buy
all these ingredients
with great intentions, like, I'm
going to cook this cauliflower.
And then during the
week, you look at it,
and you're just like, yeah,
I have no food in my fridge.
I'm going to order takeout.
So it's really having a plan,
and prepping it in advance
so that you're more
likely to use it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MALIA DELL: Yeah, good luck.
All right, well, thank you
all so much for coming today.
[APPLAUSE]